hablamos justamente sobre la primera
reacción de scholz ante la crisis entre
rusia y ucrania como cree que manejara
el nuevo canciller las relaciones con
los principales antagonistas de
occidente rusia y china- por ejemplo
gracias por el espacio andrés un gusto
estar con ustedes bueno creo que del
nuevo gobierno alemán podemos esperar
palabras mucho más claras de las que
conocemos el gobierno de angela merkel
en cuanto a la relación con rusia y
china así como también en cuanto a
violaciones de derechos humanos de otros
países me parece que vamos a escuchar
una voz mucho más decidida
señora cluster ver cómo será la relación
con sus aliados especialmente a nivel
europeo sabemos que su primera visita
será a la capital francesa el viernes
así es yo creo que va a ser una relación
muy cordial creo que hay interés por
parte del nuevo gobierno alemán en
mantener una estrecha relación con
europa en llevar adelante la unión
europea en fortalecerla
y darle más peso a europa en este
contexto y qué retos les esperan a nivel
interno por ejemplo especialmente con la
pandemia de kobe 19 y la posibilidad de
vacunación obligatoria
y seguramente será un tema a discutir en
el parlamento alemán pero la propuesta
está y creo que es una de las vías
correctas para enfrentar los grandes
retos que implica la pandemia para este
nuevo gobierno
seguramente habrá discusiones fuertes al
respecto en el parlamento alemán pero me
parece que
la iniciativa que seguramente será
presentada por el nuevo gobierno es
importante pues para poder realmente
enfrentar esta cuarta ola que estamos
viendo en este momento y la situación
que se agrava en estos días en alemania
se dice por ejemplo que yo es una
especie de continuidad de la hera merkel
al haber sido ministro de finanzas de la
ex mandataria
un poderoso puesto en la política
alemana usted qué opina sobre esta
interpretación
yo creo que habrá continuidad
eventualmente en algunos puntos pero el
hecho de que el nuevo gobierno está
compuesto por socialdemócratas por los
liberales y por los verdes va
obligadamente a definir nuevos acentos
en la política alemana alemania enfrenta
en este momento retos importantes en
temas de modernización sobre todo de la
infraestructura digital por ejemplo creo
que estos retos que se enfrentan en
materia de innovación son acentos muy
distintos a los que veíamos en el
gobierno de angela merkel y creo que a
través de
esta innovación en distintos ámbitos
como lo son la administración pública
propiamente como lo son la
infraestructura de internet de telefonía
celular van a permitir realmente una
modernización son retos muy grandes hay
muchísimo trabajo por hacer pero soy
optimista
el nuevo gobierno logrará esta
modernización tal y como la requiere un
país como alemania en este momento